what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to do a first
time watching for the film A Few Good
Men John are you doing good I am doing
great and I am a men aha that is good to
hear my friend Tom Cruise is in the SEO
and this has been one of the top movies on
our list for a while so we were like Now's
the Time to capitalize on it but before we
go into that today's video is sponsored by
nobody nobody is sponsoring this why not well you
want the truth John you guys would skip it anyway
so it doesn't matter oh that's right that's all
we know about this movie is that one question
forever through little children but yeah guys
I love me some Aaron Sorkin so I'm really late
to checking this out leave a like on this video
that'd be very much appreciated also as always
full and stretch and watch along recycle with
your own copy of a Few Good Men available for
a super sexy rejects over at our patreon page
we cover several things exclusively over there
with reaction highlights and watch alongs included
thank you to all who have joined thus far becoming
super sexy rejects let's swing into action and see
all the crazy stunts he does in the court cases
Gary Marshall direct this I forget who directed it
no I couldn't tell you you just reminded me
was Aaron Sorkin yeah this is his first movie
whoa adapted from his play okay I know
some facts behind the scenes about it
highway to the danger zone this is gonna be fun
I was like is this a hazing or
is this like an actual assault
jeezing lock the door I mean you know Rob
Ryan Rob Ryan Rob Marshall and I was like
no way that can't be Rob Marshall this
is a weird Choice Gary Marshalls would be
interesting as well but I think Rob Reiner makes
the most that makes more sense such for the time
God damn the timing
well-oiled machine Precision this is how Marine's
battle yes it's just a battle of wits and postures
Captain I'd like to request that it be me who's
the attorney no I'd like to request that it
be I who I'm assigned that's that's confidence
inspiring is she like a Jag entered the barracks
room of a PFC Williams Santiago and assaulted him
Santiago died at the base Hospital approximately
an hour later what Jesus Dawson and Downey are
both recruiting poster Marines I was thinking
it sounded an awful lot like a code red code red
I'd like to have them moved up to Washington and
assign Council in short Captain I'd like to
suggest that I'd be the one who that that it
be me you're a woman practicing the law she's
not cut out for litigation she's a hell of an
investigator Jerry an internal Affair sure she
can crawl up a lawyer's ass with the best of
them when it comes to trial work I think I know I
know all passion no Street Sports bring her back
again cool we projected the thing about it being
a woman so we are the Sexes they don't even care
yeah they're just talking about her abilities well
from what I understand from your colleagues you're
much too valuable in your present assignment to be
wasted when I'm sure a ball down to a five-minute
plea bar in a week's worth of paperwork she's got
passion I promise you divisional sign the right
man for the job all right let's go let's get to
Jack Reacher that's right military Mountain Jack
Reacher I'm gonna charge him with possession and
being under the influence while on duty you plead
guilty it was oregano Dave it was ten dollars
worth of oregano yeah well your client thought
it was marijuana my client's a [__] that's not
against the law I'm gonna file against pre-trial
confinement and you're going to spend the next
three months going blind on paperwork because the
signalman second class bought and smoked a dime
bag of oregano even in the Navy plays by his own
rules Tom Cruise before he fixed the nose eyebrows
and teeth that's right man the raw ball of clay
a marine Corporal named Dawson illegally fires
around from his weapon over the fence line and
into Cuban territory what's your fence line a big
wall separating the good guys from the bad guys
teacher's pet now do your Christopher Walken
impression go into Santiago's room stuff a
rag down his throat and an hour later
Santiago's dead attending physician
says a rag was treated with some kind of toxin
Jesus Daniel Caffey I was told to meet with uh
Commander Galloway himself what a mess he seems
like a slacker how long have you been in the
Navy going on nine months now and how long have
you been out of law school a little over a year
or about 10 000 apples when I petitioned
division to have counselor Sons I was
hoping I would be taken seriously come on your
Lieutenant captions generally considered the
best litigator in our office he successfully
plea bargained in 44 cases in nine months wow
one of the people we'll be seeing down there
is the Barrack CEO Colonel Nathan Jessup I
assume you've heard of him who hasn't it no
he's been in the papers lately he's expected
to be appointed director of operations and
National Security Council these are the letters
letters and months at gitmo it's Guantanamo
Bay where he offered information about Corporal
Dawson's fence line shooting in exchange for
a transfer this letter makes it look like your
client had a motive to kill Santiago got you
and Santiago is the victim write that down
write that down I'll get them to drop the
conspiracy and conduct on becoming 12 years
you haven't talked to a witness or looked
at a piece of paper pretty impressive huh
Commander do you have some sort of
jurisdiction here that I should know
about I'm special counsel for internal affairs
so my jurisdictions pretty much in your face
yeah oh she emphasized the diction part slap him
with it sure you're dismissed I always forget that
part yeah he's too cool for school don't worry
he's gonna learn to Care by the end of this move
yeah follow every rule to the T I'm writing to
inform you of my problems with my unit here in
Cuba I've fallen out of runs before for several
reasons such as feeling dizzy or nauseated I've
fallen back about 20 or 30 yards woof my sergeant
grabbed me and pushed me down the hill then I
saw a black and the last thing I remember is
hitting the deck whoa I wanted to provide you
my information about Eagle fence line shooting
that occurred the night of August the 2nd oh boy
who the [__] is PFC William T Santiago God I
missed Jack Nicholson I think Santiago should
be transferred off the base immediately yes wait
I've got a better idea toxins suck maybe we have
a responsibility as officers to train Santiago
yes I'm certain that I read that somewhere once
why don't we meet at the old club and have lunch
and we'll talk about the training of young William
I'd be delighted to hear any suggestions
that you might have sir dismissed I love
you sir there's just no one like Jack Nicholson
I know it's the scratch of his voice that drawl
we went to the academy together but I've been
promoted up through the chain with greater
speed and success than you have if that's a
source of tension or embarrassment for you
I don't give a [__] I really believe
that yeah but I don't think you're fit
to handle the defense it takes someone hours
to discover I'm not fit to handle the defense
it's especially Discerning you went to Harvard
Law then you joined the Navy and now you're just
treading water for the three years you've got
to serve in the Jag core just kind of laying
low so you can get out and get a real job if
that's a situation that's fine I won't tell
anyone hot shot but if this case is handling
the same fast food slick ass Persian bizarre
Manner and something's going to get missed
and I wouldn't be doing my job if I allowed
Dawson and Downing to spend any more time
in prison than absolutely necessary because
their attorney had predetermined the path of
least resistance woof the doctor's report says
that Santiago died of asphyxiation brought on by
acute lactic acidosis and that the nature of the
acidosis strongly suggests poisoning now I don't
know what that means but it sounds pretty bad
I'm gonna talk to your supervisor I was assigned
by division remember somebody over there thinks
I'm a pretty good lawyer so well I appreciate your
interest and admire your enthusiasm I think I can
handle things myself including the truth just when
you thought he had a lack of daisiac quality yeah
that's right there's duplicitous in there sir code
red is a disciplinary engagement so a marine falls
out of line it's up to the men in his unit to get
him back on track Garden variety typical what's
basic Code Red the men in his Squad would give him
a GI shower scrub brushes brillo pads steel wool
wow was the attack on Santiago kodron yes sir the
rag you stuff in Santiago's mouth was a poison on
it no sir we were just gonna shave his head sir
where'd you get the rag train him to think of his
unit before himself to respect the code what's
the code unit core God country I beg your pardon
linear priorities tune Commander Lieutenant
Jonathan Kendrick held a meeting with the men
and specifically told them not to touch Santiago
it's important information I'm going to Cuba with
you tomorrow and the hits just keep on coming
where's Tom Cruise to go back to just being
an actor I know I love what he does now but but
yeah it's like about the performance it's about
him inhabiting a role and he's playing a guy and
he doesn't have all the action to nothing rest on
that but yeah and that's not the priority Jack
Russ came to see me today he offered me the 12
years I mean I guess I'll take it up oh no he's
starting to care more something doesn't feel right
okay he said the platoon Commander Lieutenant
Jonathan Kendrick had a meeting with the men
and specifically told him not to touch
Santiago I never mentioned Kendrick I
don't even know who he is keep pulling
the thread there's more than meets the
eye maybe instead of a running Montage we'll get
a reading Montage how the hell is your dad Danny
he passed away seven years ago sir that's
not what I feel like the [__] [__]
there's a lot of really great
injection to humans yeah it's
definitely got like a surprising
wit about it I mean I guess you'd
expect that from Sorkin but at the same
time I thought this would be like heavy
his involvement I mean it seems to me that
Jack Nicholson definitely orchestrated this
kill yeah I mean that's how it feels yeah
especially with like the way he was talking
in that first scene seemed a little unhinged
Santiago is going to reveal the person's name
in exchange for a transfer yes any details that
I'm missing you should feel free to speak up
thank you
damn look at that game of cat and mouse
game on we agreed that for his own safety
Santiago should be transferred off the base
on the first available flight to the States
oh 600 the next morning oh come on dude code
red still happened on this on the spacecraft
Joe the kernel doesn't need to answer no she
outranks you Danny I want to tell you something
I would defeated
caution in your tone Commander I'm a fair guy
but this heat is making me absolutely crazy
I eat breakfast 300 yards from 4 000 Cubans
who were trained to kill me so don't think
for one second that you can come down
here flash a badge and make me nervous
holy hell never get nervous you can have all
the transfer orders that you want you have to
ask me nicely Jesus Christ power games of this
guy Colonel Jessup it's not too much trouble
I'd like a copy of the transfer order sir no
problem loves to maintain that power it's a
little Heart of Darkness right down here in
Cuba Carl markinson's gone UA unauthorized
absence did Lieutenant Kendrick order you guys
to give Santiago a code red yes sir there it is
PewDiePie she's not gonna win you a place
in my hardcore well I get paid no matter
how much time you spend in jail yes sir
I know you do sir oh he's you Harold whoa
Jesus and then he went into Dodson Danny's room
and specifically told him to give him a code red
it's not what Kendrick's Kendrick's alive you
have proof I have the defendants and I have
23 Marines who aren't accused of murdering a
lieutenant with four letters of commendation
that is a people battle right there yeah you
know what markinson did for the first 17 of his
26 years in the core counterintelligence
markinson's gone there is no Parkinson
we did nothing wrong sir we did our job and
if that has consequences then I'll accept him
and I won't say that I'm guilty sir exactly
good on you the Court decides that what we
did was wrong then I'll accept whatever
punishment they give I believe I did my
job and I will not dishonor myself my unit or
the core so I can go home in six months sir
this guy's good too Harold I did everything
I could you're going to Leavenworth for the
better part of your life and you know
what I don't give a [__] yeah you
do what happened to saluting an
officer when he leaves the room
he knows Danny doesn't care about code yeah you
know nothing about the law you're an ambulance
chaser with a rank you're nothing live with
that shots fired wow it doesn't look like you
wanted the truth there Danny it does look like
you could handle it the accuser charged with
murder conspiracy to commit murder and conduct
on becoming a United States Marine the defense
will stand to replace yeah inspiration he said
yeah not yes sir they're not guilty there it is
a man what is a lieutenant Junior grade with
nine months experience and a track record for
plea bargaining get assigned a murder case so you
can roll over yeah would it be so that it never
sees the inside of a courtroom exactly no wonder
they chose me Joe before you come over and I pick
up a carton of legal pads half a dozen boxes
red pens half a dozen boxes oh he is focused
look at this friend at the NIS she said if
Martinson doesn't want to be found We're not
gonna find him he said I could be Mark and Shannon
you wouldn't know it are you are you markinson
you can see how there's a play but this feels very
cinematic a lot of times movies that are based on
plays feel like a play but this feels like a
film now Lieutenant Kathy is going to astonish
you with stories of rituals and Dazzle you with
official sounding terms like code red you might
even try to cut into a few officers for you oh my
God he's doing the Eminem Eight Mile thing okay
you have a dumb friend named Chatterbox
Own It All in every weak point when Dawson and
Downey went into Santiago's room that night it
wasn't because of Vengeance or hatred it's
because it was what they were ordered to do
but if you're a marine you're given an order
you follow it or you pack your bags Harold
Dawson and Loudoun down here sitting before you
today because they did their job nice nicely
done a member of private Santiago's Union had
illegally fired his weapon over the fence line
the shift reported only one century returned his
weapon to the switch with a round of ammunition
missing lance corporal Harold Dawson this
guy's believably boring yep expert witness
Corporal Carl Edward hammacher Marine
Barracks rifle security company Windward
platoon Bravo is that Cuba Gooding
Jr Kendrick held on the afternoon of
September 6 with the members of the second
platoon yes sir it is show me the money
did Lieutenant Kendrick leave a
standing order at that meeting
yes sir what was it sorry said
Santiago wasn't to be touched
five minutes after this meeting no
sir thanks I have no more questions
slim narrative clear-cut the facts the defense
is willing to concede that all 22 witnesses will
testify substantially as Corporal hammacher did
if the government is willing to concede that none
of them were in Dawson and Downey's room in 1620
on September 6th yeah cut through the fair trade
cut through the fat if the muscles and other
cells of the body burn sugar instead of oxygen
lactic acid is produced that lactic acid
is what caused Santiago's lungs to bleed
gross Willie Santiago dive poisoning absolutely
dozens of toxins which are virtually undetectable
the nature of the acidosis is the compelling
factor in this issue best in trial is it possible
for a person to have an Affliction some sort of
condition which might also speed up the process
of acidosis it's possible what might some of
those conditions mean stress coronary disorder or
cerebral disorder the process would be more rapid
it's possible to have a serious coronary condition
where the initial warning signals were so mild
as to escape a physician during a routine medical
exam oh nicely done there would still be symptoms
though there are hundreds of chest pains yes
shortness of breath yes fatigue passing out all
the time yes yes would you read your handwritten
remarks at the bottom page please sir initial
testing negative patient complains of chest pains
shortness of breath and fatigue restricted from
running distances over five miles for one week
isn't it possible that Santiago had a serious
coronary condition and not some mysterious
poison that caused the accelerated chemical
reaction no why private Santiago was given a
clean bill of health because Lord knows if you
put a man with a serious coronary condition on
duty with a clean bill of health and that man
died from a heart related incident you'd have
a lot to answer for when you oh boy your honor we
renew our objection to Commander Stone's testimony
and ask that it be stricken from the record the
objections of a rule Council move to reconsider
the witness is an expert and the court will
hear his opinion the witness doesn't make
mistakes Monday the 19th at which time the defense
will call its first Witness I strenuously object
objection overruled no no
no no no no I strenuously
why do you hate them so much they tortured and
tormented a weaker kid they didn't like him so
they killed him and why because he couldn't run
very fast everybody take the night off go see your
wife see your daughter Joe go do whatever
it is you do when you're not a great time
why do you like them so much because they stand
on a wall and they say nothing's going to hurt
you tonight not on my watch smart this is so
rooted and not just what are the facts but
what is the belief yeah and how can you spin
the perspective juries are swayed by emotion
more than anything else I was wondering if how
you'd feel about my taking you to dinner tonight
are you asking me out on a date no
I've been asked down in dates before
and that's what it sounded like do you
like seafood I know a good seafood place
I think you're an exceptional liar I watch
the Court members they respond to you
I see you convincing them and
I think Dawson and Downey are
going to end up owing their lives to
you phenomenon of spending mine with
I think you should prepare yourself
for the fact that we're going to lose
whoa I mean let's pretend for a minute then
it would actually matter to this corner
I can't prove it ever happened and we'll
put on a show but at the end of the day
all we have is a testimony of two people
accused of murder Jack Nicholson that's right
that's what we'll find the truth gonna be
the account I want the truth when the time
is right when we are ready have you ever received
a code red yes sir we were doing seven man assault
drills and my weapon slipped this guy from ER
there you go it's private Santiago ever late
for platoon meetings yes sir was this Barracks
ever disorder yes sir you got a code red because
your palms were sweaty why didn't Santiago this
burden to his unit ever get one exactly yeah
Dawson wouldn't allow it to the guys talked tough
about Santiago but they wouldn't go near him
Jeffrey did you ever want to give Santiago a code
red yes sir why didn't you because Dawson would
kick my butt sir I hold here the Marine outline
for recruit training you familiar with this book
yes sir would you turn to the chapter that deals
with code Reds please just flip to the page in
the book that discusses code Reds they're not in
there well you see sir code red is a term that we
use is there no book no manual or pamphlet no set
of orders or regulations it lets me know that as
a marine one of my duties is to perform code
red you know the answer no sir no book sir I
love how he's answering so sincerely no to see
how things work would you turn to the page in
this book that says where the mess hall is please
well Lieutenant Caffey that's not in the book sir
that's so good how did you know where the
mess hall was if it's not in this book
well I guess I just followed the crowd at
child time sir ah good answer thank you sir
Oh you mean he's a little impressed that's good
that was well pleased I'm gonna use that later
I want to slam dunk this guy 1900 every time
there's another courtroom he's like
we're gonna lose we're gonna lose
my freaking ass off let that be a movie
moment for their life of what the [__]
oh is it uh what's his name yeah I know
everything was it a code red yes did
Kendra give the order yes he was never
going to be transferred off that base
we're going to McDonald's they need some food to
stock Cocoa Puffs you've got the transport it's
got your signature I know I signed him the morning
you arrived in Cuba five days after Santiago died
I don't want a deal and I don't want immunity
I want McDonald's Jessup said that six the next
morning was a first flight Santiago could have
left on markinson says there was a plane that left
seven hours earlier you just concentrate on Downey
I'm gonna talk to Ross tell them where we are is
is that guy going to die I don't want him to die
I don't I feel like he'll be exonerated I'm going
optimistic and I want to tell you that I think oh
[__] bunch of you are certifiably insane this
code of honor of yours makes me want to beat the
[__] out of something I'm your friend and I'm
telling you I don't think your clients belong in
jail but I don't get to make that decision wow now
I want you to acknowledge that the Judge Advocate
has made you aware of the possible consequences
involved in accusing a marine officer of a felony
without proper evidence I've been so advised it's
true we were here to witness that you got bullied
into that courtroom by the memory of a dead lawyer
Papa can you hear me Lance corporal Dawson's
ranking after the school of infantry was perfect
what's Dawson's promotion held up because of
this last report I'm sure it was could you read
it you recall an incident involving a PFC Curtis
Bell who'd been found stealing liquor from the
Officers Club did you report private bill the
proper authorities the only proper authorities
I am aware of are my Commanding Officer
Colonel Nathan R Jessup and the Lord our God
I knew that was coming Lieutenant
do you know what a code red is
yes I do have you ever ordered a code red no I
have not did you order Dawson two other men to
make sure the private Bell received no food except
water he was given water and vitamin supplements
and I can assure you at no time was his health
in danger sure it was lovely for private bill
sick to eat vitamins with no food wouldn't this
form of discipline be considered code red no if
I called the other 478 Marines at Guantanamo Bay
to testify would they consider it a code red well
he's a court the witness Lieutenant Kendrick was
Dawson given a rating of below average on this
last report because you learned him in sneaking
food to private Bell object not so fast Lieutenant
I want to hear that one yeah he disobeyed an
orders because he made a decision about the
welfare of a marine that was in conflict with
an order of yours he was punished is that right
but the code Marine if you had ordered Dawson to
give Santiago a code red I specifically ordered
those messages disobeyed you again Lieutenant
don't answer that you don't have to I'm through
to order Lance corporal Dawson and private
Downey to give Willy Santiago a code red
always hesitating no I did not thank you I'll
tell you hesitated he was rattled the first
flight Stateside left Guantanamo Bay at 2300 it
arrived at Andrews Air Force Base Maryland is a
few minutes past two in the morning what are you
telling me you fixed the logbook that's the only
conclusion you don't still intend to put me
on the stand Thursday morning 10 o'clock oh
boy it was bad well but Marcus didn't understand
and we'll deal with jessup's refusal to transfer
Santiago and he'll testify to the forage transfer
and that'll be enough that and downy's testimony
really ought to be enough I feel like something's
really going to happen to him I feel like he's
not going to make it to the trial I was ordered
to give him a code red by the platoon commander
of rifle security company Windward Lieutenant
Jonathan James Kendrick you're gonna do fine
sure do you remember the order of the questions
yeah are you sure yes I know you small words yes
because he gets Rattle and he doesn't understand
so I'm just saying go slow I'm gonna go slow okay
building building Dear Mr and Mrs Santiago
I was William's executive damn it damn it
he's gonna do it isn't it I was really
worried to do this I wasn't strong enough
to stop it always Lieutenant Colonel
Matthew Andrew markinson damn it man
why did you go to private Santiago's room a
code red was ordered by my platoon Commander
Lieutenant Jonathan James Kendrick you're
Witness dark and stormy night the pickup
private got a flat sir right at 39 he pulled up
and Bam blowout with no spare I'm guessing it
must be a good hour by foot am I right pick
of him he did it in 45 Flats sir good man
an order that Lieutenant Kendrick gave you in
your barracks room in 1620 am I right yes sir
what you just said that you didn't make it
back to the windward Barracks until 1645. oh
damn it well you see sir there was a blowout
private did you ever actually hear Lieutenant
Kendrick order of Code Red well Hal said that
private did you ever oh no why did you go into
Santiago witness has right the witness has been
read his rights Commander the question will be
repeated Santiago's room always turn into hell
now carpet answer the captain's question woof
as Captain I was given an order by my squad
leader Lance corporal Harold W Dawson United
States Marine Corps and I followed it does look
up to him huh yup damn it guys Danny wasn't in his
room that was an important piece of information
don't you think Danny it was a setback but we fix
it and move on to markinson markinson's dead yeah
really gotta handle those Federal Marshals boy
this guy got into full dress uniform
stood in the middle of that room
drew a nickel-plated pistol from his
holster fired a bullet into his mouth
why did you ask Jessup for the transfer order
you could have gotten it by picking up the phone
and calling any one of a dozen departments at the
Pentagon you wanted to see jessup's reaction when
you asked for the transfer order exactly what
possible good could come from putting Jessica
told Kendrick to order the code red that's great
why didn't you say so and of course you have proof
well for our defendants it's a lifetime at
exotic Fort Leavenworth it's a car Marshall
yes Johnny after falsely accusing a highly
decorated marine officer of conspiracy oh gosh
jeez thank you for playing should we or should we
not follow the advice of the galactically stupid
all is not lost this is not the Dark Night
of the soul that is required right now
that's how you know you're almost to the victory
I'm sorry I lost your set of steak knives
woof [__] and this a picture of me in the shower
wrote a paper about your father in college one of
the best trial lawyers ever and if I were Dawson
and Downing I had a choice between you your father
to represent me in this case I'd choose you
any day of the week and twice on Sunday oh
10 times the lawyer Mufasa was could
you put chess up on the stand nope
not a Lionel caffeine or Sam Weinberg our lead
counselor for the defense in the matter of U.S
versus Dawson and down you are ma'am wwtcd joke
get in the car Joanne please get in the car
we got him got a little jog I'm
gonna put Jessup on the stand
kiss me full Hollywood this movie's so effective
at knowing to keep Jack Nicholson as more of a
looming presence and build him up threaten the
Shadows yeah he's always so powerful yeah and
I think he's pissed off that he's got to hide
from this I think he wants to say that he made
a Command Decision and that's the end of it
he eats breakfast 300 yards away from 4 000
Cubans that are trained to kill him he's doing a
technical center I need my bad I think better with
my back where's my back toss me about put it in
the closet don't ever put that bat in the closet
what's in that closet what did you see oh
there's evidence hidden back here magical bat
Sam I need you to do something for me
blowing this thing wide open you feel
like he's not gonna say it don't
go for it you could get in trouble
oh you're not suggesting that I back off a
material witness if you think you can't get
him yeah given that extra ounce of steaks yeah
light that fire oh man he's gonna risk it all
where's Sam he's on his way he's got some piece
of evidence he's coming gotta get the truth even
though he can't handle it the witness is aware
the court is aware but we thank you for bringing
this to our attention move on Lieutenant yes
sir who are those guys uh they're gonna blow
this thing wide open I ordered markinson to have
Santiago transferred off the base immediately I
felt his life might be in danger once word of the
letter got out grave Danger is there another kind
not into guantanamos Santiago's Barracks room was
sealed off and its contents inventory
I'm wondering why Santiago wasn't packed
your honor these are the telephone records from
gitmo for September 6th and these are 14 letters
that Santiago wrote in nine months oh my goodness
upon hearing the news that he was finally getting
his transfer Santiago was so excited that do
you know how many people he called zero nobody
he was asleep in his bed at midnight and according
to you he was getting on a plane in six hours
yet everything he owned was hanging neatly in his
closet and folded neatly in his foot lock
oh yes guys get scripted you packed a bag
and made three phone calls Santiago
was leaving for the rest of his life
and he hadn't called a soul and he hadn't packed
a thing that's good that's [__] good Santiago
wasn't going anywhere isn't that right Colonel now
it's my recommendation sir that Lieutenant Kathy
be reprimanded for his conduct and the witness be
excused with the Court's deepest I know the judge
looks like he's uh your objection is noted I'm
gonna keep an eye on this I want the truth colonel
maybe he was an early riser and like to pack in
the morning these two marines are on trial for
their lives please tell me that their lawyer
hasn't pinned their hopes to a phone bill
Jesus thanks Danny I love Washington excuse me let
me dismiss you I'm not through with my examination
sit down I always made a choice I'd
appreciate if he would dress me as
Colonel or sir I believe I've earned
it he probably did that intentionally
that's when I developed my drinking problem the
witness will address this court as judge or your
own I'm quite certain I've earned it oh [__]
he's losing respect stripping him down you don't
own this trip his pride down this isn't your
office your honor these are the tower Chiefs
logs for both Guantanamo Bay and Andrews Air Force
Base I don't understand you're admitting evidence
of a flight that never existed well we believe it
did Sir there's the where's the mistake they were
working the ground crew at Andrews at 2AM on
seven oh [__] Colonel a moment ago check the
tower logs for Christ's sake well we'll get to the
Airman in just a minute sir you know let's just
get it to him and Lieutenant Kendrick was clear
on what you wanted Crystal any chance Lieutenant
Kendrick left your office said the old man is
wrong no never we follow orders or people die
it's that simple are we clear and
people are we clear crystal crystal yes
if you gave an order that
Santiago wasn't to be touched
and your orders are always followed
and why would Santiago be in danger
why would it be necessary
to transfer him off the base
great question you said he was being
transferred because he was in grave
danger that's correct you said he was in
danger I said grave danger you said Israel
your own words in Lieutenant Kendrick gave
an order that Santiago wasn't to be touched
and why did he have to be transferred
tenant Kinder quoted the code red Denny
because that's what you told Lieutenant
Kendrick to do object when it
went back cut these guys loose
oh [__] did you order the code right
you don't have to answer that question
I'll answer the question oh God you want
answers I think I'm entitled it's coming
true you you can't handle the truth yeah you
have the luxury of not knowing what I know that
Santiago's death while tragic probably saved
lives oh [__] I don't give a damn what you
think you are entitled to did you order the code
red I did the job you're goddamn right I did yes
I suggested members be dismissed so that we
can move to an immediate article 39a session
the witness has rights Captain Ross give me a
second approach Genesis imploding case called
him jack his friend damn that's a great scene
that was a tremendous true climax MP's got the
colonel yes sir whoa getting arrested man I'm
being charged with a crime a trial by Court
martial is that what this is or administrative
I'm being charged with a crime oh God this is
Spence I'm gonna rip the eyes out of your head
and visit your Dead skull oh [__] Jesus you
put people's lives in danger you got a man sweet
dreams son don't call me son I'm a lawyer and an
officer in the United States Navy I am the son of
a very and you're under arrest you son of a [__]
the witness is excused you've got a man killed
you've got one of your own killed in a minute to
slow my heart down it's crazy how like that one
scene does live up to like you're like no wonder
that's a quote Yeah it's like such a crescendo
what comes after this Powerhouse active yeah I
don't know what happens after that on the charge
of murder the members finally accused not guilty
one you won the charge of conduct Unbecoming
a United States Marine guilty as charged
and you are ordered to be dishonorably discharged
from the Marine Corps you got punished for the
thing though that you said you were okay with
getting punished for yeah they did kill a man
I mean yeah following orders is
not a good excuse Colonel Jessica
episode Red what did we do wrong it's not that
simple what did we do wrong we did nothing wrong
yeah we did we did it he was supposed to fight
for people who couldn't fight for themselves
he was supposed to fight for Willie oh poor
guys hey man we're in charge for murder them
you don't need to wear a patch in your arm to
have honor 10 hot there's an officer one day oh
uh the real verdict is respect Cameron cecilom
Allen Anthony Rodriguez what exactly were
these guys going to testify to unless I'm
mistaken they're both going to testifying or
oath that they had absolutely no recollection of
anything they just needed to sit in the courtroom
where's your legacy sequel Tom
yeah good Jack Nicholson out
of retirement for one more
who did he kill on the inside
damn
what a film yeah that was great yeah that was
fantastic still that feels Timeless truly let's
do the math here 10 20 30 years ago 31 okay
yeah 92's came out yeah yeah 31 years ago
and that holds up like I don't know just
as much as it ever did especially you know
being that it surrounds like Guantanamo
Bay and that just makes Tom Cruise's
face today that much more impressive than what
he does today though holy [__] it's 31 years
ago this guy's business a long time uh yeah now
I thought it was an incredibly compelling story
like I love a good courtroom drama and it they
made they made it very like character driven
and had all the heart and nuance and yeah do I
think like Aaron Sorkin is is a little bit more
a little bit more Punchy and more fun now I
think this is quip energy there's like a sort
of Aaron Sorkin energy you know like that there's
a stabilization of his dialogue over time that is
present here but is less like in your face yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's this this doesn't feel
like something I would say about Tarantino like
this doesn't it feels like a Sorkin script but
nowadays you can like watch something and be like
that Aaron's working right this way yeah whereas
this feels just like um you know like a a passion
piece that got him off the ground because like I
said at the beginning it's based on a play and
then it got made into a movie and I I think here
it was it was a phenomenal piece of work uh the
the acting all around was amazing and the other
thing I really knew about it was Aaron silicon
wrote it and stars Tom Cruise Demi Moore and
Jack Nicholson I wasn't aware of how little Jack
Nicholson would be in here but whenever he's here
he's such an effective presence and the fact
do you kind of keep him in the shadows makes
whenever he shows up that actually that much
more threatening versus checking in with him
a bunch because everyone else is constantly
building up the hierarchy the ranks uh the
it's like it explores this this line of when
does it become you know a code amongst your
Brotherhood and when is it just a cult you know
yeah yeah exactly and what is you know following
the reasonable chain of command versus what
is something that you know morally you should
object to even though it might lead to you know
protocol based uh you know repercussions or or
Consequences or something like that like it's you
know it's it's the examination of you know at what
point should you not just follow orders and you
see the danger represented nicely between the
two defendants because you have the one that is
clearly I keep mixing their names up but you have
the one that's clearly like much more uh outwardly
intelligent and and clearly the losses sort of
yeah in charge and then you have the other one who
you know is is gonna follow whatever this guy says
and trusts him and so it's like yeah you've got
these two people you know on the hook for this one
of whom is just following his buddy who he looks
up to and the other one who thinks he's doing The
Honorable thing and uh and yeah it's like it's
it's great because I think the way they lay
everything out you know they give you just enough
to know what the truth is but also to see just how
murky it is from a law standpoint from a legal
standpoint yeah I let you they let the audience
get involved with the complicated nature of what
everything is going on like they let you have the
discussion and kind of go well yeah I mean I'm not
really sure what's right or right it's not black
and white like that's why I think the punishment
served at the end is not this romantic Hollywood
ending yeah of they get off of it and they just
get a second chance at life you know like they
get a punishment but they also get a clear their
name of being murderers you know I thought that
was really well orchestrated to go down that
path because you even have it amongst the the
def the the defense team the defense Council you
know they they all have like you got Debbie Moore
who's incredibly empathetic and sensitive to this
situation then you got Kevin Pollock who is uh
repulsed by the situation he believes they deserve
to serve time in court and he finds their actions
um abhorrent and you got Tom Cruise who's the one
going through the massive character trajectory Arc
of someone who's just like I'm just here to do a
job let's call it quits let's call it a day it's
just another case and then he's fighting himself
getting really emotionally entangled yeah over
the course of this and finding something to care
more about uh than just himself just doing a job
just to get it over with I think the way they and
but the way they have the discussion around the
particular case like it's a fascinating subject
because normally we're dealing with like a crime
was committed yeah and it is that it is it is
life and death it is a crime was committed that
it's all circling around this thing I've never
heard of before I don't know if it's a real thing
um but the code red subject yeah I've never
I've never heard I mean yeah they have of
course it's like a hazing yeah of course
seen movies amazing with discipline yeah
um yeah but I'm not I'm not familiar with that
specific terminology are you I'm not no I don't
know if that's like a thing they made up here or
if that's based on some real sort of Unwritten
military code or something like that yeah yeah
and I I like how it um it deals with the subject
matter of is that okay to do like I feel like
that's a real thing in in some even if it's
not exactly what it's called code red I feel like
there's some truth to that type of discipline yeah
that's sort of like the unit has to discipline
each other other as a means of pulling closer
together and also being independent enough but
also in line with their superiors but they even
have a um they even have a gray area with that
of how sometimes it's been affected like they
had that Noah something the guy who plays in
an ER yeah Noah I don't know his last name yeah
um I think it's Noah it's his first name I can
almost see it um but when he was there he was when
he was testifying he was saying like no it helped
him become a better Soldier and like he's even
laughing about it like he the way he looks back on
that memory of receiving the code red punishment
he's smiling about it he looks back on it fondly
like he grew as a person due to it yeah yeah
um but you know like everyone else is being what
they're exploring here that other people are are
falling behind and [__] you know uh or they're
they're slacking here this this guy this guy who
was who was killed he wanted to be out he wanted
to be transferred like it's it's a completely
different thing and it's and that's where the
cultish mentality comes in of no you're gonna
we're just gonna Stick it to you you know yeah
well it's clearly a matter of yeah he's not just
you know a bit sloppy or disengaged it's like this
is actually kind of a threat and detriment to his
health and well-being he's been misdiagnosed by
the doctor he's passing out all over the place
and and you know you only get a brief glimpse of
him when he's alive but that one scene in the mess
hall you can just feel how like isolated and alone
this dude is when also simultaneously being forced
to you know harmonize with a bunch of other
people who are being you know he's being sort
of unfairly you know put into these circumstances
where everybody and and then expect it to perform
alongside everybody else and so yeah like I I
love the whole I just the the whole deceit of
the debate about them basically saying like no
we got to keep him here like you know it's uh
if we transfer him that's only gonna lead like
like I it's so despicable but it becomes like
the exact opposite argument to the public versus
internally when they're like yeah no we gotta you
know Hammer this guy down and you know shape him
and mold him and we can't you know accept no for
an answer basically on that front yeah and it's
it's fun seeing what Jack Nicholson did with this
role of a guy who's just so set in his old school
ways and refuses to if even though there's like a
law implemented which I think is smart to put
in the movie again I don't know what's actual
truth too that is reflective or what's made up
here it would all be based on something but I
think that's smart because that immediately
tells you what they did is illegal yeah
like regardless what they did is illegal so
you're telling the audience it's certainly
wrong so there's no question about it because
it's good it is it is illegal what they're doing
this is not on the books so let it go yeah
so I think that was that was very clever but
um yeah I think Jack Nicholson makes for a quite
a formidable villain like Demi Moore's presence
here I think that it was great that they did
not actually have her hook up with Tom Cruise
yeah I was just thinking that um because when they
started going the seafood data I was like uh here
we go here's the Hollywood yeah at the end they're
gonna kiss yeah they're like this is gonna be the
start of a beautiful relationship I'm really
glad it didn't go down that path because that
would have I think undercut the movie quite a bit
and her character too yeah it would it would have
underserved her character the tension is enough
to to add some character Stakes but yeah it's it's
not so much that it eclipses the actual point
of why we're all here and and yeah like I like
that you know even though there are moments where
people are being unprofessional or or whatever you
know they're mostly sticking to the case and the
proceedings and you know unraveling all of that
and responding to the emotional ups and downs of
the case rather than like interpersonal melodramas
and things like that well I think the arc for uh
the Dany characters well constructed too because
so much of this is about you know dealing with
uh your higher ups mentors whatever it may be
answering to some type of authority Legacy yeah
and he is dealing so much with uh living in his
father's Shadow and having him make his own
identity in his own choices as well and they
don't I mean they take moments to like talk about
it so it's clear to the audience but there's not
like a horde amount of scenes that are dedicated
to it yeah but his personal Arc is reflective of
the uh decision making that the people he's
defending have had to deal with too you know
so while they're different different subjects
you can see how thematically they're similar so
I thought that was that even though it's a it's
definitely an archetype of what that especially
now I don't know like preceding this movie How
often that was the case but after this movie for
sure seeing that kind of art type a billion
times yeah living in your father's Shadow
uh which is a fine archive to me because it's
like a thing a lot of a lot of people deal with
um and I thought that was a perfect choice
though for why for to reflect the whole
movie thematically overall oh yeah um because you
know like within the Marines any type of military
unit you become family with people so I'm told by
all them uh you it is like a family and you're in
the shadow of your Superior officer who's sort
of like you know a dad of sorts even with the
um even with the two who have to defend themselves
that is that doesn't feel like soldiers it feels
like an older brother taking care of a younger
brother who's not as capable you know yeah 100
so they kind of strip away a lot of the a lot of
this is like stripping away the the actual Law and
Order and the codes it's just stripping away the
pageantry and the protocol and the formality of
the situation yeah really just cutting down to the
facts into the morality at Play you know and the
and yeah like the inherent risks and negligences
that went into this and and yeah the just the way
the these machinations can you know lead to these
like really horrible nasty things that often just
slide under the radar and yeah it's like it's just
one person compared to however many and like you
know even Nicholson you know being the antagonist
so to speak or at least you know sort of the the
Pinnacle as of this case of you know the real
intent uh I thought they still managed to draw him
in a way where like yeah we're not really supposed
to like get on board with or agree with him but I
didn't feel the movie too much hating the
character on our behalf if that makes any
sense like we see him from a limited perspective
but I don't know I I really thought Jack Nicholson
inhabited him like he's got all of his jackness
he's got that sort of thing where you're like oh
yeah this guy's probably not a Savory dude but at
the same time I could see how he would arise these
ranks with respect and get to the position he's
in in as hellish of a place as it seems Guantanamo
Bay would be well the movie does a good job along
with his performance and especially the writing of
him because yeah you know they always say like a
good villain doesn't believe he's the villain of
the story he always believes he's right right he
believes he's actually the protagonist and he's
this guy certainly does to the point though where
it's like parts of it are very convincing and like
this movie rides a Gray Line uh with a lot of
the subject matter including all the things the
characters are dealing with but especially with
Jack Nicholson's character you know like yeah I
don't know what it must be like to like when the
way he's talking about like all these the general
public and all the fanciness that we have to put
up here like you said pageantries that's what the
world sees but they don't know they really don't
understand the kind of ugliness that we live in
they'll never be able to comprehend the harshness
we deal with and every fear that we have to live
with so yeah sometimes we have to make some ugly
decisions because that ugly decisions what keeps
this country safe I'm like yeah I mean I I cannot
fathom how hard the decision-making must be and
what it must do to kind of make you a little bit
colder and a little bit more ruthless because that
ruthlessness is what keeps you alive so yeah I
have no idea so when you're hearing them like I
get that point yeah oh yeah that's part of what
makes that climactic scene so great is like you
don't agree with him and you know that his actions
directly led to this man's death and that should
be you know Justice should be served there but
at the same time you're like no I get I get where
you're coming from though I can't fathom half the
[__] you're talking about I wouldn't want to be
in your position whatsoever and I can only assume
that there is no good way to go about any of this
yeah and so yeah at least yeah I thought across
the board like the characterizations were very
graceful and very well fleshed and all the actors
I thought across the board were well Chosen and
did a fine job and yeah like I would be fascinated
I can kind of Envision how this might be a play
I can imagine sort of like okay maybe you'd have
the courthouse set the office you know the little
house where they're you know breaking down the
case and maybe a couple other sort of you know
interstitial things but it does really seem like
you know this transforms into you know a move like
I would be fascinated to know what is different
how much of this you know is directly transcribed
or not because again I would if you didn't tell
me that this was a play I would have never guessed
well I imagine this that's for a Rob Reiner skills
really came in handy here sure of being able to
go we need them to travel we need to see them
travel we need to see them outside because most
of this movie is is in interior locations most
of this movie is people just having conversations
at interior in like the last half is mainly
the courtroom case and but you know they got
certain moments where like they're traveling to a
base they're in a car you know and so and little
things like that but even on the interior scenes
they never felt like they were just a play no and
that's my problem with most play adaptations is
I'm like I might as well just watch the play too
now watching famous people yes yeah I'm watching
Hollywood actors instead of Broadway actors yeah
uh and and yeah I thought the way that they also
I think it's especially s you know of a movie the
way that they show you the facts of the case
and they show you just enough it's like they
show the two guys breaking in on Santiago in the
beginning and just you know the beginning of that
situation and then we cut to the aftermath of that
situation we see a couple of like perspectives on
Santiago that you could get from just other you
know soldiers that counts and then you're in the
room when you know the the order comes down from
Jack Nicholson and that's it's like enough to
for us to know the truth but it's also enough
to accentuate the idea that like well if this
one guy is obviously Kiefer Sutherlands not gonna
cave to this line of questioning and uh and uh TJ
Nelson Has removed himself like yeah you can you
can see it's like they don't show you the whole
thing but they give you just enough of the facts
and just enough of the you know fly on the wall
perspectives to be like I know the truth and it
I also know how this does look as bleak can dire
and impossible as they say because it does just
ride on one guy verifying this account yeah and
I thought it was great too that they left they
don't actually confirm that he gave the code red
order like you know yeah but they you don't have
anyone you had they cast doubts on the uh manowitz
Markowitz the guy who ended up unaliving himself
yeah they cast doubts about his okay even though
you're like no no he's definitely telling the
truth but the fact that you just don't even give
us a scene where you the way how they gave us the
scene of when he is talking with Kiefer Sutherland
and stuff about what to do with Santiago I love
that they waited for that Mo they've waited for
the finale for him to to finally affirm it
yeah it's like you get the initial deceit of
him being like no I'll transfer this guy we're
gonna say we're gonna transfer the guy but yeah
not getting the actual account of whether he gave
the order yeah you know um and I really do like
I thought I might find it distracting to see Tom
Cruise no and I was like no this is he's he's
great in this he's so believable yeah and I've
transported to Tom Cruise of this time because
he's been a great actor for a very long time
and I think now more than ever you feel like
you're just watching talkers but um but because he
kind of does play like a certain type all the time
maybe this was like the type he played back then
this is like a young hot shot who has to you know
rise it's really good at what he does when you get
him invested because he did that like The Color of
Money uh Top Gun this I'm like well looking back
at his younger like this was the kind of rules I
guess he would do but this is yeah but even more
than Color of Money which had a lot of physical
aspects to it with him playing pool if you look
at Top Gun um you know obviously the plane flight
sequences the aerial sequence is there here it is
just acting he's that's all he's doing is it is
pure acting right here and he's acting his ass off
in a way that is a very human performer a lot of
charm yeah he's got his big moments a lot of it is
just like a guy he's just a natural guy yeah and I
I I've been wanting for a long time for Tom Cruise
to kind of just go back to dude I'm like forming
will the public want that maybe not like we're so
we we expect him in these like huge summer movies
and it's what saved his career after you know um
tainting his puppy his personal and yeah after
attaining his personal image where he was putting
his love life in religious life on you know full
display and then people are still always trying
to expose him for that you know and he's managed
to like make everyone shut up about it because he
keeps like trying to kill himself on screen here
can you forget about my problematic aspects
now and uh I I love I love the movies he does
and I love I love the Tom Cruise we have
today but I've never forgotten like he's
an amazing actor though and and a lot of that
is overshadowed by you know the crazy stunts
he pulls off and now yeah and this is just a
reminder such a testament to him yeah he's he's
a phenomenal actor and nikoi said the action
Daniel Day-Lewis and the drama Jackie Chan is
but wouldn't Daniel did you lose just be
the drama Daniel Day Lewis and Jackie Chan
sure but this this this was this was the doctors
doesn't become these people yeah the people
become he's a very emotional he's committed he's
committed but he doesn't stay in character yeah
between tapes like I think he does a full backs
I know I know his acting method is he does a full
back story he loves to know the entire character's
history like he really does love to know the whole
lineage of how this character came to be so he
knows his character's thinking and feeling in
this very moment so I I do believe that um but
you know like there's a but he knows how to like
turn it off when it's not yeah the camera's not
when it's not his yeah he seems like the kind of
guy who who especially as a producer and stuff
needs to keep the set as pleasant as possible
so he can't afford to be the character off screen
that heavily yeah yeah but you know I feel like
now it's there's a certain type of Lady and that's
that was kind of what was fun about him in Top Gun
Maverick was it was a little bit bringing it back
to the performer yeah yeah that he's like oh he's
he's kind of just he's a guy he's just a guy
he's not like action leading hero yeah though
he has those scenes he feels like a relatable guy
really skilled guy yeah in a tangible position and
and I think here it's it's really fun it's
a fun time capsule to watch because it is
you know you kind of witnessed the lightning in a
bottle of Tom Cruise because it has that Duality
to his performance where on the one hand you're
like this is like a textbook what people think of
when they think of a Tom Cruise performance he's
got the smile you know he's got this you know the
sort of messy but Suave attitude he's in a you
know position of power obviously he's you know a
a lawyer for the Armed Forces but uh at the same
time it also just feels like that was right for
the character and that's Danny you know he's a
care you're really rooting for him to win you're
rude like when he has that moment when he has
to choose like I thought they set the stage just
nicely but there it wasn't just like Demi Moore
just showed up to introduce Stakes like they were
they were setting that up yeah um throughout the
film like you you press a certain you know uh high
official too hard then you're gonna you're gonna
get like this barred you know um and that moment
where he had to choose you're like I'll [__]
choose yeah I did make the choice we want you to
make like you really root for him in this movie
it's been a while since I've really rooted for
him that yeah didn't involve like you know save
the day and then yeah and a scenario in which I
think when it becomes the bigger the stakes become
I think the more of a foregone conclusion it is
that he is going to Prevail whereas something like
this feels so high stakes but if you don't know
you know if you haven't seen it you it could go
either way I mean obviously when he gets the you
know ultimate climax out of Jack Nicholson you
know where it's going to go but for so much of
it like they they it's a testament to the writing
of the character the performance by Tom Cruise and
the whole array of circumstances but yeah like you
really do sort of sweat and you're like we need
all of the prowess of Tom Cruise to maybe have
a hope of scraping this by and that feels real
rather than just like you know yeah it's exciting
and it's death defying so there's that element
and it's possible but you know he's gonna be
fine whereas here it's like I don't know like
this is yeah it's a different playing field it's
a little more grounded it's still like as it's got
a it's still like thrilling like I do appreciate
a movie like this because like I think a lot of
legal dramas are quite engrossing and enjoyable
in many ways but they're not always as like
you know something about this still feels
action-packed almost even though you're
not watching like an action movie that's a Sorkin
writing man yeah exactly he knows how to do that
yeah he knows how to keep things he loves energy
he loves fun and he loves heart he loves having
humor like I love Aaron sorkin's writing I really
I really love his writing well and going back to
that thing you said earlier like like being that
this is you know an earlier part in his career it
still had so much humor while also having you know
that heft and that researched you know literary
quality to it and you know this was a a you know
it's a heavy movie Heavy circumstance but it was
a lot more like enjoyable there was a lot more you
know I thought we were walking into that too yeah
I thought we were walking into like a heavy drama
yeah and it's like it's not funny but it's like
it's funny the way like life is funny you know
like yeah it's it's there's charm in life and in
the between moments you know between uh you know
big intense testimony or whatever they're gonna be
some lighter moments and yeah it felt very natural
and it also happens to play on Tom Cruise's again
natural sort of Charisma charismatic charm yeah I
was just saying it's good with dialogue he's great
with dialogue like let him act yeah he's good
at committing and being sincere and again like
he's just got it he just has the yeah he just has
that that movie star thing I hope when he realizes
like you know I am a senior citizen I should
probably dialed back some of this stuff up to
her house when he does get to that point he
just he just continues to go back to you know
I'm acting again every three years let's just put
it in time make it sound like I don't love what he
does now because I I am in love with what he does
now it's just yeah I'm talking even just go back
to the collateral you know yeah like just that's
not that far along like even collateral well there
was action in there like that's a performance
yeah something that's a little more grounded
that rests more heavily on the performance than on
the physical and the and the set pieces yeah yeah
something that really calls upon him to act and
also you know hopefully I mean not to dog any big
action movie but I think you know the the smaller
you scale it potentially the more interesting the
character work may become and the circumstances
if they are more tangible might be a little bit
more vital and Tom Cruise yeah I think it's I
think that's part of it is we're used to him now
as this God you know as this guy who is willing
to risk life and limb for Cinema uh and I want a
little bit more Tom Cruise just the man again
because this is like a a great reminder of how
wonderful that can also be and I know he still I
know he's an older guy now but he's still got all
of the assets that he's showcased in this movie
The performances of what he does now are very much
reflective of like I'm I've been obsessed with Tom
Cruise's like life and career for a very long time
and I think the performances of what he does now
is very reflective of who he is as a person in
real life because he does have this like insane
hyper-focused Vigilant um you know loves to learn
type of mentality like there there was if you've
watched there's one interview on like Corden where
he was rattling off the amount of like licenses
that he has for the many things from you know a
helicopter plane a real estate license like he's
got a gazillion and he's serious about that like
he shot all these things he loves to learn he and
as he he's a lawyer whereas a lot of past the bar
whereas a lot of celebrities probably whereas a
lot of celebrities as they get more successful
and famous they kind of like to keep relaxing a
fine ways to like calm down and relax a little
bit more and have fun gain some weight whatever
yeah yeah he's used that those opportunities to
become smarter more educated more of this like
machine and anyone who's on set he would love to
like learn what the crew was doing and stuff and
and inquire and really absorb and that's that's
the best way to probably describe him is he is
like a sponge and yeah so what he does now is this
um you know accumulation of all the things
he's learned over the year yeah well yeah and
he puts it on the big screen like he learns these
things and he puts it on the big screen like and
that's what's what I love about what he is now
because dude you are watching Tom Cruise that
he's learning but it's also got a narrative put on
top of it yeah he loves to learn about all these
things and and and so I I love what he is now
because you do see that is like this is the most
Tom Cruise you're getting other than like you're
not listening to the Scientology stuff but this is
the most stalkers you're getting uh it feels like
he never lost that hunger like you know like as a
younger actor yeah it's like as a younger actor
you know you gotta acquire more skills and take
risks and try things and then you reach that point
where you're like fully arrived and people just
offer you whatever and I feel like that can yeah
like you said be kind of an excuse to maybe you
know ease off the gas asked with that but I feel
like yeah Tom Cruise just like has always had that
yeah he's just he's an extremist yeah yeah and
it's just like okay I'll learn this thing now I
gotta go learn some more things yeah you know he
is a really whatever beliefs he might have that
you might disagree with at the end of the day
he is they were is he it seems to work and no
wonder they want him to be the poster boy for that
religion because look what he is saying look what
he is defying he constantly gives all his praise
and thinks like I am this way because of this you
know um and I I feel like this so it's like can
he can he do something like this again you know
that's that's the question though is he even
interested in something like this again that's
the uh yeah I mean that's the big question to me
and right now it doesn't feel like it so much but
what is I mean right now it's Mission Impossible
which he's gonna do until he's 80. well everything
he does he puts his finger on turns into Mission
Impossible you know no it does like so night and
day was Vision impossible what the [__] The
Mummy was mission Impossible everything's Mission
Impossible yeah even when we roll I mean top gun
Maverick is its own thing but a lot of the leeway
to being able to make the movie that they made was
because yeah it also at least carries that aspect
of he's gonna do some crazy [__] yeah that's
great yeah he's gonna risk his life for us yeah
I mean like it's more of a risk I would imagine
now because you know doing a mission impossible
wherever he happens to be doing it in franchise
or out seems to be like this safest Tom Cruise
like part of me does wonder if it's maybe a little
restricting being in that position where you know
Mission Impossible works but what else do we know
right now that like just works for Tom Cruise and
I mean that's like a scary thing but like I
would love to see a swing at like something
more dramatic or comedic or something yeah just
a little bit more comedy stuff for so long I've
seen it forever he is such an underrated comedic
actor he's pushing for uh Tropic Thunder too or
whatever he's in a highly back for that highly
underrated even here you see this comedy chops I
mean he's so he's got great time he's a funny guy
he's really funny and he doesn't get a chance to
the Mission Impossible kind of shows it now but
you know topical Maverick kind of shows it but
he's an underrated Community grudging into Mission
imposs like after seven odd movies he could be fun
sometimes yeah I I really it is this is looking
like a time capsule of of the kind of performances
he used to do yeah and I feel like the Jeremy
wire time is when he started morphing into
I'm the guy who just Smiles at everything
yeah sure like it's like he would go from
like really Charmed super intense like those it
was like these this this big obvious Paradigm
of performances of like Jerry Maguire shows
that War of the Worlds shows it sure where
he's like I'm super charming and smiling so I'm
super against you know yeah I guess that's the
Nuance yeah this seems to ride a gradual line
that is very much just sort of on the back of
the development this is very natural yeah
like he's just a guy and I and I kind of
I don't know if he is I don't even know if he he
can do that now it's such a thing he's not that in
real life not bad guy because I feel like nowadays
he has everything that's on display in this movie
but yeah like the natural levels I would be
curious to see like as I feel like probably
at this time he was more like this kind of guy and
then who's like because it's such a fine line to
me because this says again this is like it's a
very Tom Cruise performance but this is clearly
not at the point where yeah it is just like oh
Tom Cruise is doing the Tom Cruise thing even
though all the things are are present so I feel
like it could happen you can even Jack Reacher
and it is like super Intense or like you know
the occasional levity and there's like there's
pretty hard lines between those things yeah
and so I would like I would love to see it
I would love to see a movie where Tom Cruise
has to go back and be like how do I just be
how am I just a guy who am I just naturally
respond to the situation at hand and there's
no sort of global threat involved yeah it's
just in real life a movie that doesn't make
an opportunity for him to have to run yeah
I think his part of the key because this
didn't really give him an opportunity much
at all to like do that much that's physical
I just want to say too I love him and Jerry
Maguire and War of the Worlds action I think
it's great I've seen more of the worlds you ever
seen Jerry Maguire no no one has shown me the
money wow you haven't seen Jerry Maguire no it hit
me on your list I know because it hit me during
this when you show me the one at one point when
you were getting Junior showed up you said you
had me at hello I know because it's a Tom Cruise
related quote Yeah it's just that's another it's
like you can't handle the truth it's just one
of those like things that has been uh yeah you
know yeah grafted into my subconscious without
the full context yeah I love that movie dude
um alrighty well I knew this would turn
into a Tom Cruise discussion ten minutes
I know when we get to the review we're gonna be
talking a lot about like what happened to this
guy yeah yeah how far we've come because yeah
it's a fascinating tale of what he is yeah all
right guys well what do you think about A Few Good
Men leave your thoughts down below what are your
nitpicks do you wish Tom Cruise would kind of go
back to doing roles like this leave your thoughts
down below um thespian what time is it for us it
is late but hey not late enough to do a patreon
or Hague if I ever needed to go to court and I
wanted someone to defend me it would be you I
would love for Tyler hay to defend me because you
see a big part of having a lawyers more than just
facts and the evidence the information no you
gotta buy into the defense attorney You Gotta
Buy into their personality and you were just
so warm and friendly and sincere and just so
relaxed I feel like they would even let you
do it via Zoom oh true I agree with anything
think no matter what they'd be like he's got to be
telling the truth listen listen to this guy look
how sweet he is he's such a sweetheart this guy
wouldn't represent someone who's guilty no that's
not the Tyler Hague way everyone want to just
hang out with you they won't even care to hear
about the defense the jury would stop you know
they're like look we believe you he's innocent
the case is thrown out tell us about you Tyler
you want to go grab some breakfast that's what
would happen let's play some games Tyler thank
you so much for defending us at every turn I
can't wait for you to represent me am I murdered
slash Thief trial yeah murder slash Thief suspect
Greg with the best defense attorney in the damn
country Tyler Haig thank you buddy get him off